I like covering what's happening in the
news media world and one of the sort of
more interesting stories of the last
couple years has been megyn kelly who
started in media as a news reporter
after working as an attorney she then
became a contributor on Fox News she
ultimately got her own program on Fox
News and then she had this very public
spat would then candidate Donald Trump
where it was ultimately announced that
she'd be leaving Fox News to develop
programming for NBC News which would
include a weekly Sunday night program as
well as a daytime talk show and
immediately it was obvious that this was
a very clearly big big money for her
NBC News was sort of making a play on
Megyn Kelly's name rather than her
specific skill set or the demographic
that she appeals to and it was clear
that these weren't really her key
competencies or her sort of
bread-and-butter when it comes to format
and NBC News but a huge amount of money
on her right three year 69 million
dollar contract crazy money but it has
been a total unmitigated disaster and it
keeps getting worse and back in October
we talked about it I told you things
weren't going well her nighttime
interview show they got Vladimir Putin
which was a big deal but otherwise
totally flopped they made a huge deal
out of their major blockbuster interview
with conspiracy theorist Alex Jones not
exactly the person you'd imagine a
program with this budget and this amount
of fanfare on corporate media would tout
as like a major get as one of their
first guests Alex Jones her daytime show
did okay for like a week then lost half
a million viewers within that at the end
of that first week and a lot of it was
Meghan Kelley just didn't seem authentic
in this format and it has continued to
get worse and worse since we talked
about this in October and there's a
really interesting Wall Street Journal
article about it now let's remember Wall
Street Journal is owned by News
Corporation News Corporation owns Fox
News could they be writing a negative
article about megyn kelly because of
sour grapes it's possible but they're
making fact-based points and the
fact-based points are continued really
low ratings on the daytime show which
have local NBC affiliates unhappy
staffers on other NBC shows reportedly
upset about how much money
Megan Kelly's show gets despite the
horrible ratings Hollywood agents
reportedly are telling their clients not
to even go on Megyn Kelly's show because
of low ratings and because of this
really weird incident where megyn kelly
interviewed Jane Fonda not for very long
it was a short interview and chose to
ask Jane Fonda about plastic surgery and
it did not go well and then the
nighttime show which I'm barely talking
about I'm barely talking about it
because it's been all but canceled
there's no weekly nighttime show anymore
it's an occasional special episode like
a primetime special type of thing so was
this a mistake for megyn kelly I don't
know I mean financially not at all right
69 million for three years that's great
for her financially the problem is that
if she carries herself if she carries
her worth on more than just ratings and
on prestige then arguably this is a big
mistake
NBC seems to have really been the one
that made the mistake here right NBC
calculated that her personality
justified this amount of money and it
seems that this is bigger than megyn
kelly it seems like personality doesn't
drive corporate news shows to the tune
of 69 million dollars over three years
right there's no question that the big
personalities on corporate media do
Drive revenue but is it to the point of
69 million for three years apparently
not and corporate news ratings in
general have been down as there are more
alternatives independently and on the
Internet
some of Megyn Kelly's Fox News
demographics they don't really translate
to daytime talk shows right typically
the people that are watching the nine PM
partisan Fox News primetime show or
10:00 p.m. whatever time she was on
those are not the same people watching
daytime talk and who would even
potentially be in Megyn Kelly's audience
so this has not worked well for NBC
megyn kelly is going to be fine
financially but I'm curious about the
future of this format bigger picture I'm
also curious how much longer NBC is
gonna allow the daytime show to continue
right I wonder what megyn kelly will do
after this three-year contract is up
yeah will and NBC re-sign are probably
for less money if they do
I don't think she can go back to Fox
News especially because there's probably
bad blood there she did write something
negative about Roger Ailes who allegedly
you know well he did actually I mean he
doesn't allege she was actually well
actually keep there were payoffs but of
course he passed away that I don't think
that their world to me any interpreted
proceedings there
yes but Roger Ailes by all accounts
massive payoff to gretchen carlson and
and other women i think she doesn't go
back to fox news for sure i think it's
possible that she gets shifted around in
NBC News she could maybe get reframed as
sort of just a news reader maybe she
becomes the next like half-hour news
person on NBC News but certainly a for
me the most interesting thing has been
whether or not she is a right-wing
ideologue the right-wing ideologue
character that she played on Fox News
does seem to have hurt her potential at
these news new programs so total
implosion of Megyn Kelly's new shows
both shows in fact okay I wasn't going
to talk about michelle wolf and the
White House Correspondents Dinner since
we normally don't really say much about
it but the scandal around it has made me
want to have a conversation about it and
what was notable this this year about
the White House Correspondents Dinner
was that Trump didn't attend normally
the president goes they get roasted to
some degree and they generally take it
pretty well Michelle wolf headlined the
event in Trump's absence she made jokes
some were aggressive some were less
aggressive some were very funny some
were not as funny but she's getting
absolutely crushed by conservative media
and even some on the not right like not
left wingers per se but even just sort
of some general media criticism is
saying that maybe michelle wolf went too
far and the normal MO with these things
is the people being made fun of it's
usually the president people in the
current administration sometimes media
as well they sort of all take it in
stride right because it doesn't look
good when you don't and then the
partisan al analysts from the
administration's party will slam the
comedian is going too far or being too
aggressive or being insensitive or
distasteful when it was Obama you'd hear
a little bit of that from the left but
mostly it was understood that this is
comedy right it's comedy and it's comedy
period the right has absolutely lost its
mind over Michelle Wolf's joke saying
everything from it was bullying that was
Mike Huckabee who said that - it was
cruel unfair disgusting inaccurate and
this is so funny on so many levels first
and foremost being the same free speech
warriors who were supposedly against the
trigger warnings and the safe spaces are
effectively totally triggered by
michelle wolf and arguing that she just
went too far and they wanted in practice
the White House Correspondents Dinner to
be a safer space for them than it was I
mean just a glaring hypocrisy but I
thought we should actually look at what
Michelle Wolf said because what really
seems to be getting to them is that
everything Michelle Michelle wolf said
other than like the clearly sarcastic or
joking comments was true right she
opened with a joke about a porn star
having sex with Trump that happened or
at least there's every indication that
it happened she said Congress
accomplishes very little that's true
most people in the United States degree
she said that at age 32 she's 20 years
older than the age that would make Roy
Moore find her attractive more hasn't
denied pursuing girls not that much
older than 12 right it's an edgy joke
but it's a fine joke to be making she
referred to Michael Cohen writing a
hundred and thirty thousand dollar check
to someone he did that what's the big
deal she joked about the liberal media
being turned on by the Trump Russia
collusion story that's a critique of
liberal media why would conservatives be
mad about that
she said Hillary wasn't in contact with
Michigan that's a critique of Hillary
Clinton's campaign she joked about Trump
phoning into Fox & Friends
he does phone into Fox & Friends all the
time why is that a big deal she joked
about maybe Trump isn't as rich as he
says he is well we know that that's
something that bothers Trump it's not
original material others have suggested
that she said Trump is a racist I mean
yeah that's a matter of debate but it's
not really unique or controversial at
this point to say that Trump has racist
tendencies she suggested that a Trump
impeachment might be bad because it
would lead to Mike Pence who's worse
I've been saying that and many others
have been saying that for more than a
year I don't see how that's offensive
she joked about people being against
abortion until their secret mistress
needs an abortion that's a real story
about many Republicans and even some
anti-choice Democrats when it comes to
abortions only for their mistresses and
not for anybody else she joked about
Republicans having not see candidates
that just happened in Illinois that
actually is a real thing
she said Kellyanne Conway lies that's
undeniably true she said Ivanka has done
nothing as a women's rights advocate I
would agree with that and then she got
into Sarah Huckabee Sanders and this
made a lot of people mad she joked that
Sarah Huckabee Sanders is like aunt
Lydia in a Handmaid's Tale she accused
Sarah Huckabee Sanders of constant lying
she joked about Sarah Huckabee Sanders
being a disappointment to women is this
really that bad like you would only
really be triggered by that if you
recognize that it's all completely true
and then she made a joke about Sarah
Huckabee Sanders Smokey Eye Makeup and
people said well as she's starting to
make fun of Sarah Huckabee Sanders
appearance give me a break
they should all be thrilled that that's
the full extent to which Sarah Huckabee
Sanders appearance was ridiculed right
and I've been very clear I think Sarah
Huckabee Sanders is terrible for the
lies that she tells but one could if
they wanted to as Trump did to many of
his opposing Republican candidates
ridicule the way they look
joked about Fox News having a problem
with predators of women I mean that that
is true that's true
made some jokes about Rachel Maddow
that's not even about the ride she said
Trump is so broke that he grabs [ __ ]
looking for loose change I mean that
that relates to news stories if this is
offensive speech to Republicans they are
even more thin-skinned than we thought
and we thought they were pretty damn
thin-skinned and I feel like if there is
legitimate criticism to make here it's
that these aren't really jokes for the
most part there were just like
observations about reality yes and I
think that's why comedians nowadays are
having such a tough time in the era of
Trump because reality is already pretty
hilarious so there's nowhere to take it
I mean you can't like flip it you can't
make it satirical you can't exaggerate
it and then they could argue that it
wasn't funny that would be a criticism
but most people don't get offensive by
things that aren't funny they just don't
laugh and then move on
their lives so it appears that what the
right really hated about Michelle wolf
speech was that it contained mostly the
truth there's one other angle here which
is that because Michelle wolf did go
after corporate media in a lot of ways
corporate media may have decided to
enable Michelle Wolf's critics to come
on and slam her because she slammed them
during her jokes that's another possible
angle which is interesting yeah it could
be a silver lining that this could take
down the White House Correspondents
Dinner they're actually talking about
getting rid of the comedy not only over
this incident but also Stephen Colbert's
roasting of George W Bush yeah that
would be a great thing I think the
Correspondents Dinner is a little bit
too cozy between the media and those in
charge so well I'd like to see them get
rid of it listen you got rid of the
president this year they can get rid of
the jokes next year what will be left I
guess just like a a dried fish dish that
gets served to everybody in the room I
don't know what else they'll have we
have a major story today to lead with
and it sort of goes directly to possible
crimes committed by President Donald
Trump and his campaign but it also goes
to corporate media effectively falling
hook line and sinker for what was
clearly a calculated decision that was
made and this all relates to the sum of
a hundred and thirty thousand dollars
which was paid to adult film actress
stormy Daniels by Trump's personal
attorney Michael Cohen and to give you
the 15-second reset on the story Donald
Trump allegedly had an affair with
stormy Daniels years ago close to
Election Day 2016 she was paid a hundred
and thirty thousand dollars in hush
money
she was also asked to sign a
nondisclosure agreement and the story
that we've been told so far is that the
hundred and thirty thousand dollars came
not from Donald Trump nor from Donald
Trump's campaign which would potentially
be illegal but from Michael Cohen
Trump's lawyer personally and that
Donald Trump neither knew about the
payment nor the non-disclosure agreement
nor did he ever repay Michael Cohen the
hundred and thirty thousand dollars this
was unbelievable from day one right
first and foremost because Donald
Trump's name is on the non-disclosure
agreement Trump didn't sign it
but in principle how can people be
parties to contracts they don't know
exists doesn't really make any sense and
in addition to that it was always hard
to believe that the hundred and thirty
thousand dollars which Michael Cohen had
to mortgage his house to obtain were
never returned to him by the billionaire
Donald Trump it always seemed like a
legal and PR manipulation to claim that
Cohen paid the money just out of the
goodness of his heart out of love for
Donald Trump as Michael Cohen's attorney
said to megyn kelly a few weeks ago well
in comes Rudy Giuliani former New York
City Mayor one of the latest additions
to Donald Trump's legal team which is a
legal team that's been constantly in
flux since it was put together and
Giuliani goes on Fox News last night and
he says oh yeah a Donald Trump did pay
Michael Cohen back for the hundred and
thirty thousand dollars which obviously
contradicts the idea that Trump didn't
know about the payment
it obviously contradicts the idea that
Donald Trump didn't pay Michael Cohen
back which is what we were told and
hypothetically it means that there could
have been a crime depending on whether
the source of that money was Donald
Trump personally or the Trump campaign
but it also potentially eliminates some
other crimes so let's get to the video
clip here is Rudy Giuliani on Fox News
last night I was talking about the
hundred thirty thousand dollar payment
right a settlement payment which is a
very regular thing for lawyers to do the
question there was the only possible
violation there would be was it a
campaign finance violation but usually
were result in a fine by the way not
this big storm of storm troopers coming
in and breaking down his apartment and
breaking out his office that was money
that was paid by by his lawyer the way I
would do out of his law firm funds or
whatever funds doesn't matter the
president reimbursed that over a period
of setting me it said it didn't I will I
distinctly remember that he did it on
his own he did without asking look I
don't know I haven't investigated that
no reason to dispute that no reason is
for the recollection I like Michael a
lot you like Michael oh yeah I feel very
bad he's been victimized like this the
president feels even worse by the way
again Sean Hannity saying he's known ko
in awhile without mentioning he actually
worked with Michael Cohen but
that's that's not even gonna that's not
gonna rate today rudy giuliani after
this interview told the New York Times
that this isn't just something he's
saying but that he has documents which
show that Donald Trump did make this
payment so the obvious question is why
admit this all along Trump claimed that
he didn't pay him back didn't know about
it seems like an unforced error right
wrong this is a calculation much like
the calculation with Russia collusion
remember there was no collusion shifted
into a narrative of if there was
collusion it wouldn't be a crime and it
wouldn't be illegal anyway among some
right and here they are obviously
calculating it's better for them to
shift from there was no repayment to
repayments for settlements are totally
normal
obviously any client is going to repay
their lawyer for a settlement that was
made and part of the calculation is that
Trump astaire that Trump directly lied
about this it is not a slight distortion
it's a straight-up lie right let's be
super clear Trump was asked specifically
aboard Air Force One last month did you
know about the payment to stormy Daniels
and Donald Trump said no and said talk
to Michael Cohen he was then asked do
you know where he got the money to make
that payment and Donald Trump said no I
don't know rather than well yeah he got
it from me because I paid him back
Giuliani isn't stupid he is a hyper
partisan guy he has said a lot of things
that don't make a lot of sense but he's
not stupid and clearly there's been a
determination made here that the legal
danger is bigger if Trump doesn't repay
if tump Trump didn't repay Cohen because
that would potentially raise more legal
issues than the idea that hey this is
just a client paying back their lawyer
it was alone it was a prepaid settlement
money whatever right as long as Trump
didn't pull the money from his campaign
fund it wouldn't be illegal and the
calculation that was made and I believe
it was accurately made is that framing
Trump as a liar is the best thing here
because he's never been held to account
by his supporters for lying all the time
about everything what's just one more
lie right and then now the next step in
this is Trump tweeting and shifting the
story again saying it wasn't even really
a repayment specifically for the hundred
thirty thousand dollars Trump just
regularly paid retainers to his attorney
Michael Cohen this is actually genius
check out this series of three tweets
this morning where Donald Trump said mr.
Cohen an attorney received a monthly
retainer not from the campaign and
having nothing to do with the campaign
from which he entered into through
reimbursement a private contract between
two parties known as a non-disclosure
agreement or NDA these agreements are
very common among celebrities and people
of wealth in this case it is in full
force and effect and will be used in
arbitration for damages against Miz
Clifford Daniels the agreement was used
to stop the false and extortionist
accusations made by her about an affair
despite already having signed a detailed
letter admitting there was no affair
prior to its validation by Miz Clifford
and her attorney this was a private
agreement money from the campaign or
contributions played no role ro ll by
the way instead of ro le in this
transaction America 2018 make America
great again this is where we are now and
this is a you know when Drudge Report
has this for hours as their main story
it's not a mistake by Giuliani it's a
calculation and corporate media has
fallen all over themselves to report it
as a major unforced error which I just
simply don't believe it is I've talked
to off and on about Jordan Peterson
who's quickly become known as a sort of
stunning and innovative intellectual by
pseudo-intellectuals and anti
intellectuals and anti sjw's and I've
basically characterized Jordan Peterson
as an anti sjw self-help equivalent to
Deepak Chopra with a hidden twist of a
Christian agenda and I'm not going to
recreate my entire criticism of
Peterson's rhetoric here but the long
and short of it is that he became known
for miss stating what Canada c16 bill
would have done with regard to
transgender pronouns he used that
notoriety to publicly promote his again
Deepak Chopra like teachings which if
you want a critique you're told you're
either miss stating Peterson's
statements or you just don't understand
what Peterson is saying
and he's grown this massive income for
himself on the basis of appealing to the
Santa SJW crowd so what I want to do
today is look at a specific video that
was posted on our subreddit that goes to
an example of the hidden Kristin a
Christian agenda that many people just
don't see or know about Jordan Peterson
he recently debated friend of the show
Matt Dillahunty who I've interviewed
before and at a certain point during the
debate Peterson makes the ridiculous
claim which is that even people who say
they are atheists actually do believe in
God deep down maybe so deep down that
they don't even know it because if they
were actually atheists they wouldn't
have a moral compass and might be mass
murderers because you can't actually
have that moral compass without
accepting religion in some way maybe I'm
misunderstanding or misstating what
peterson said I'm sure his followers
will say that so let's take a look at
the video yeah I've tried for years I
had this thing going where people would
say oh and this is kind of what we're
getting out from different angle I would
say they would be afraid of what we
would lose if we lost religion and I
basically said demonstrate to me any
benefit oh you'd lose art and poetry and
drama and narrative library are there
are there no godless artists and poets
there are artists and poets who think
they're godless so we might have crossed
over into a problem area yeah I don't
actually I can't draw for crap although
I do draw during the show
but one of the individuals who came to
the show the other night handed me
something that she had spent a great
deal of time drawing she's a wonderful
artist I'm very grateful to get it and
you know while I pretend to read minds
on stage I constantly acknowledge that I
can't actually read mine so I can't tell
you whether or not she actually believes
in a God but I can tell you that I
actually don't believe in a God and I
could read yeah coach for you huh buddy
act like you do that's why you did I say
I'm off the stage no now you're making a
claim okay so I'm telling you I don't
believe there's a god and yeah your
response to that is
I really do because I have a moral sense
but my moral sense is utterly without
any appeal to a God explicitly or
implicitly maybe the that's not so
obvious ok it's really because these are
you regard sam harris as an implicitly
valuable entity as otherwise you just
throw them off the stage and then the
question is well just exactly why is he
an implicitly valuable entity i don't
say metaphysics of that I don't think
he's implicitly valuable in the sense
and the first and foremost this is a
hypothesis that is unfalsifiable right
the idea that atheists believe in God so
deep down that even they don't know it
you can't test that and therefore it is
not of any effective value what's saying
what he's saying effectively is that it
might seem like you can be a good person
and have a moral compass and not believe
in God but in reality the reason you're
a good person is because you believe in
God even if you don't know about it and
that's what prevents you from being a
mass murderer or throwing sam harris off
of a stage how does this pass as
intellectual thought right this is an
example of the nonsense that he spews
wrapped up in being against social
justice warriors and transgender
pronouns and his audience just eats
everything up because they like the anti
sjw stuff and the app the underlying
belief system and bias that's at play
here is atheists are secretly religious
and that's a really common thing among
true believers like Jordan Peterson
which is he can't really conceive of
someone having a belief system so
different than his so he finds an
explanation that deep down they must
believe in God because yeah he doesn't
see them committing mass murder or
throwing people off of stages I don't
know how any so-called non-religious
skeptic type can follow Jordan Peterson
and fall for his nonsense and I don't
get how the so-called free speech
warriors fall for it either since his
entire rise to fame was based on
misstating an issue of free speech that
c16 bill but I do want to congratulate
Jordan Peterson and I'm not doing this
sarcastically genuinely he's laughing
all that it all the way to the bank with
the stuff
he has built a fantastic business model
on the basis of appealing to these
individuals and there is a ton to be
learned from jordan peterson but it has
nothing to be learned about his there's
it's not actually things to be learned
from his teachings it's about how you
can wrap yourself up in this anti sjw
free speech stuff and have people accept
you almost as a god-like figure and give
you their money yea when his patreon
account numbers were public he was
making sixty thousand dollars per month
yeah I don't know where it's that now
but he also has his new book oh yeah I'm
like the speaking tour is very lucrative
business model that's really is similar
to Deepak Chopra in that way as well who
also has a very very lucrative business
model and I mentioned that earlier but
he's also similar to the preacher dudes
that say donate donate donate and then
they buy themselves a private plane with
the money not that Peterson is buying
himself a private plane but it's the
idea of those guys who will sell you a
really well wrapped up package that
makes you say I'm gonna give them the
money and then you don't even really
know in the end what you're actually
given the money for so not surprising
but a lot of people unaware of the
underlying sort of Christian dogma of
Jordan Peterson will take a break and I
will talk next to Deborah's ATS about
when markets don't work I've said before
that the White House press corps really
needs to make it a habit of not allowing
Sarah Huckabee Sanders to move on to new
questions until she actually answers the
original question that's asked by the
press corps and as I have suggested many
times if one reporter asks something and
Sarah gives a non-answer and quickly
calls on someone else the next reporter
should restate the question
etc etc until you get something that
actually counts as an answer and earlier
I already played for you a really weird
statement about Trump's medical records
being seized from his former doctor
Herald Bornstein and in order to find
that clip in yesterday's 20-minute press
briefing I actually watched almost the
entire thing and I know but which by the
way I don't really recommend people do
it's not a good thing to do I know just
watching the briefing yesterday that she
simply doesn't answer questions and
often straight-up lies in order to avoid
answering questions so I've got a couple
of examples for you
first one is a question I was hoping
would be asked and we talked about this
last week and the backstory is Trump has
a long history of saying only guilty
people plead the fifth right only guilty
people refuse to testify or refuse to
talk innocent people just tell the truth
last week we learned that Donald Trump's
personal lawyer Michael Cohen would be
pleading the fifth so the obvious
question for the White House for Trump
for Sarah Huckabee Sanders who speaks
for the White House is this Trump's
guiding principle that pleading the
fifth implies guilt apply to Michael
Cohen good on the White House press
corps they asked Sarah Huckabee Sanders
this yesterday listen to her answer or
what really is a non-answer and how she
lies her way out of answering the
question I just wanted to ask you about
something that took place last week
involving the president's personal
attorney Michael Cohen he in court
documents asserted that he would assert
his Fifth Amendment rights and historic
Daniel's lawsuit which was filed against
both him and the president and you may
recall that in September of 2017 the
president and a campaign rally said the
mob takes the fifth and he also said if
you're innocent why are you taking the
Fifth Amendment do those ideas also
apply to Michael Cohen does the
president stand by those comments I
can't speak on behalf of Michael Cohen I
prefer interested so her answer is I
can't speak on behalf of Michael Cohen
the question was what does the president
think what does the president believe
does Donald Trump stand by his comments
this is a straight-up lie by Sarah
Huckabee Sanders right if the question
had been what does Michael Cohen think
about whatever then she could say oh I'm
the White House press secretary I don't
speak for the personal lawyer an
arguably formal performer personal
lawyer of Donald Trump Michael Cohen
just replace the nouns here with a
simpler example and you'll see why this
is absurd
Sarah does your sister like Will Smith
as an actor sorry I can't answer that
because I don't speak on behalf of Bill
Smith well well hold on I was asking
about your sisters opinion about Will
Smith not about Will Smith's a
opinion on anything not an answer an
out-and-out lie she's there to speak on
behalf of Trump in the White House and
that's what the question pertained to
not answering the question another
example
Sarah Huckabee Sanders yesterday asked
about whether the White House leaked the
supposed roburt molar questions by the
way since this press conference this
press briefing we found out that they
did right here is Sarah's answer to that
question but a former assistant Special
Counsel Robert Muller has suggested that
the White House was behind is he wrong
once again I can't comment on anything
regarding those questions and I would
refer you to the president's question
about about specifically the white being
involved in it is actually specific to
the President and that's why I'm
referencing and referring you to the
president's personal attorneys who can
speak on that question this is it's such
a circular semantic game right she's the
White House press secretary meaning that
she is out there to explain to people
what Trump and his Oval Office have and
have not done Trump is part of the Oval
Office
she's asked about the White House and
she says well the question is about the
president not about the White House so I
can't actually answer that the question
is about the president's actions within
the context of his administration the
Oval Office and the White House I would
argue that this is more disgraceful than
Sean Spicer which was who was Donald
Trump's first press secretary in many
ways because these are now becoming
shameless attempts at maintaining a
policy of total opaqueness rather than
transparency Sean Spicer was a clown
comical liar but he was not so brazenly
attempting to simply obscure and not
give information and to some degree the
out-and-out lies are kind of less
disgraceful than a policy of total lack
of transparency that we're seeing from
Sarah Huckabee Sanders of course
combined and sprinkled in with lies
yeah Sean Spicer had better sound bites
I would say and he was already he was
like the liberally told to lie as well
exact whereas
Huckabee Sanders her bloopers don't
stick out to you as much but that
blooper reel is getting longer
it's an undertone of depravity rather
than just comical lies that clearly Sean
Spicer had been directed and listen this
is no defensive Spicer it's just a
criticism of Sarah Huckabee Sanders that
her behavior is even more disgusting
than that of Sean Spicer and this is
exactly when the White House press corps
should just not allow her to move on
without a real answer right I've been
suggesting this for a year they probably
will not do it because there's some fear
of losing access I'm guessing the White
House will just kick out people who
insist on not allowing Sarah Huckabee
Sanders to move on but that really
wouldn't be Pro free speech would it the
way the White House claims that is is
its policy so disgusting I I don't even
know how was I was able to stomach an
entire Sarah Huckabee Sanders press
briefing and it was only like 19 minutes
yesterday I refused to do it
oh yeah I plan not to do it again for a
while so that that's hopefully the last
we'll be hearing from Sarah for a little
bit I wasn't going to talk about this
because I know that it's waiting into a
minefield the likes of which I may not
be able to stumble out of but it's got
to be discussed at this point and I'm
talking about rapper and hip-hop artist
Kanye West's recent comments about
slavery and Donald Trump I've never
liked Kanye West I've never liked this
music I've always found it to be
repulsive as a person which is why it
might surprise some people that I'm
actually not ready today to go on the
attack per se against Kanye West because
I think there's a really good chance
he's genuinely suffering from
psychological illness and that it's
really sad or that he's joking around
and I don't really think the things even
he's been saying sound like jokes to me
but they're not the things somebody
would say seriously if they're of sound
mind and I know some will say David
don't excuse stupidity by blaming it on
mental illness that's not what I'm doing
I genuinely think there's a good chance
this is not a well person and this all
started last week when Kanye West
tweeted a picture of himself wearing a
bright red make America great again hat
which made people question what is it
about Donald Trump that Kanye West likes
it led to Kanye ending up at gossip show
TMZ's newsroom where he said that he
believes 400 years of enslaved black
people was a choice at
to some degree and he appeared on the
show with this truly depraved favorite
by the way of the so-called Internet
free speech warrior enclave named
Candace Owens let's listen to it it's a
couple minutes long it's worth it we're
playing only video because I think TMZ
is aggressive with copyright claims
let's take a listen to what was said I
don't think people necessarily
understand what happened last week with
the great American make America great
again hat what are you trying to do with
the message you're sending well it was
really just my subconscious it was a
feeling I had you know like people were
taught how to think we're talking how to
feel we don't know how to think for
ourselves we don't know how to feel for
some people say feel free but they don't
really want us to feel free and I felt a
freedom and first of all just doing
something that everybody tells you not
to do I just love Trump that's my boy he
like you know it's like so many rappers
you look at a video of Snoop Dogg love
and trunk but then he get in the office
and I don't know loving like Trump is
one of raps favorite people right but we
we talked about this that before he was
elected president people in hip-hop big
it was it was an in thing to put Donald
Trump in your rhyme somewhere and by the
way I am in hip-hop but I'm not just in
hip-hop I'm a black person too by
communicating but I'm not just I feel
like one thing is people try to minimize
me to artists hip-hop black community
yeah I'm always gonna represent that but
I also represent the world you hear
about slavery for 400 years for 400
years that's not like a choice like he
was there for 400 years and it's all
y'all you know like it's like we're
we're mentally in prison
alright so this went on longer and later
on Kanye took to Twitter to try to
clarify or explain and he said something
like once again I'm being attacked for
presenting new ideas the reason I
brought up 400 years was because we
can't be mentally imprisoned for another
400 and apparently that clarification
didn't go over too well because he then
deleted it from Twitter so it's really
important number one to understand this
for what it said and number two not to
analyze it for something that it isn't
or more deeply than it needs to be
analyzed
the idea here is Wow famous black guy
and entertainment guy two communities
that are statistically not big
supporters of the Republicans in the
Republican Party saying he loves Trump
slavery was a choice
sounds like the outright there are
people online saying the reason Kanye is
getting attacked for what he said is
because he's not playing the role that
he's expected to play as a black
entertainer and that he just has
different ideas and you're just not
allowed to do that because Hollywood and
the liberal elite don't allow for
dissension in the ranks or whatever
Kanye's getting slammed because he said
dumb things that have no evidence behind
them whatsoever period whether it's a
black guy or not or someone on my
youtube comment thread or a political
commentator comments like black people
chose to be or to remain slaves for 400
years what is the sort of intellectual
value of that I would argue effectively
nothing and in the end this may be
nothing more than an attempt to promote
Kanye West's upcoming albums what's
clear is that sometimes in order to
really understand something you need to
look at multiple layers and do a super
deep analysis and understand the various
ways in which good points might be made
not here right this is just someone
who's saying nothing remotely deeper
interesting it's being used by some
horrible elements of the American right
to their advantage and there are three
options here and it's the Trump playbook
right there there were always three
options when it came to Trump and his
supporters outrageous incompetent or
mentally ill and I don't say any of
these three and joking right Kanye West
maybe is being salacious and incendiary
merely for self-promotion which is
horrible maybe he's saying uninformed
things which he doesn't really know
anything about or he actually might be
mentally ill and that wouldn't be
something to make fun of as I've said
before it would just be sad because when
I listen to that video it doesn't sound
like a well person to me but in any case
number one the comments shouldn't be
celebrated and number two we shouldn't
pay them more attention beyond ensuring
that the comments don't end up doing
damage to communities that we care about
and when the alt-right starts saying wow
guys making a lot of sense that's when
it actually does start to do damage to
those communities that we do care about
send me your thoughts I
no there will be people who disagree
with me I'm on Twitter at D Pakman and
the show is on Twitter at David Pakman
show
so as I've already told you to reset the
story big news over the weekend
Russian lawyer from the Trump Tower
meeting l'Italia vessel Nets kaya who we
were told had no connection to the
Kremlin no connection to the Russian
government just a random private lawyer
acting independently she has actually
admitted that she was a Russian
informant that she is a Russian
informant
so my question immediately was how is
Donald Trump going to react how will he
explain this one and Trump did not
disappoint
the explanation is so absurd that it's
difficult to even explain it to you so
I'm gonna be playing the clip which is
one that took place right after the news
breaks Trump had another one of these
bizarre campaign style rallies really
really weird and to make it even more
unusual Trump showed up with a bright
red face unclear if it was a sunburn or
anxiety just bright bright red almost as
red as the make America great again hats
that you'll see in the background if
you're watching the clip with us trump's
explanation in short is that Natalia
vessel Nets kaya isn't a real Russian
spy but Putin realized that Trump was
crushing Russia so badly that he
directed Natalia vessel Nets kaya to say
she's a Russian spy in order to make
Trump look bad and of course the
insanity of this if that is that if
Putin directed vessel Nets Kyah to say X
Y or Z then that's actually Putin and
vessel that's kaya working together so
it's sort of like is when you say is it
true that this statement is false like
either way it doesn't really make any
sense here's the clip of a red-faced
Donald Trump with his hypothesis I
guarantee you I'm tougher on Russia
nobody ever thought in fact do you have
you heard about the lawyer for a year a
woman lawyer she was like oh I know
nothing no no now all of a sudden she
supposedly is involved with government
you know why if she did that because
Putin and the group said you know this
Trump is killing us what did you say
that you're involved with government so
that we can go and make their life in
the United States even more chaotic look
at what's happened look at how these
politicians have fallen for this junk
Russian collusion give me a break
this is just the best right she's not
actually working with Russian government
it's actually just that Vladimir Putin
told her what to say which of course is
a way of being in touch with Russian
government uh III I'm almost
flabbergasted by this and of course
Trump ignores the email evidence which I
mentioned earlier which also points to
her being connected to the Russian
government for years so I wanted to fend
Donald Trump here just in a tiny little
way he's completely clueless about most
things we shouldn't take anything he
says seriously I had forgotten about the
blind submission of the committed
Trumpets to the wacky stuff that Trump
says so it's interesting to watch them
not along and and they don't even really
know what Trump is talking about but to
provide full deference to Trump it is
the type of thing that someone like
Vladimir Putin might do right to say
that someone that was in touch with the
Trump campaign is actually a Russian
informant merely to sow chaos like it's
not actually crazy to think Putin would
do that but that would then mean that
they are working with the Russian
government so it actually goes
completely against what Donald Trump's
overall narrative is and it also would
ignore the fact that we have email
evidence that Natalia vessel Mnet's kaya
has been working with the Kremlin for a
very very long time so just amazing
because Trump's defense is proof of what
he's trying to disprove by issuing that
defense truly amazing times that we live
in send me your thoughts about this you
can also discuss it on our subreddit at
david pakman.com slash re d di t